lité de plurielles et fadila mehal
fondatrice des mariannes de la diversité
présidente de la commission culture
patrimoine et mémoire du conseil de
paris vous est également membre de
l'observatoire parisien de la laïcité
bonsoir fadila mehal bonsoir alors au
lendemain du 8 mars journée de la femme
vous publier un ouvrage intitulé
marianne les femmes et la diversité dans
la république aux éditions de l'atelier
j'ai le livre entre les mains c'est un
livre d'histoire autant qu'un manifeste
politique avec de nombreuses photos de
femmes d'origine étrangère qui ont aidé
à construire la france telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que toutes ces femmes ont en
commun fadila mehal ben écoutez je vais
vous dire je suis parti de deux
réflexions en fait je dirais presque de
deux interpellations
la première c'est ma fille ma fille de
28 ans qui me disait maman il faut que
tu arrêtes avec des revendications sur
le droit des femmes
maintenant nous avons atteint tout ce
que nous souhaitions à la fois sur
l'emploi sur la possibilité de la
contraception et tant d'autres choses et
elle me disait finalement on a des
acquis vous avez bien travaillé
maintenant consacre toi autre chose et
là j'ai eu vraiment un coup de semonce
parce que je me suis dit mais elle ne
s'est pas la réalité des droits des
femmes et l'historique des droits des
femmes la question et c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu reprendre pour un siècle
comment les femmes se sont battus pour
leurs droits leurs droits essentiels
leurs droits d'intégrité d'abord
physique après elle a la possibilité
d'intégrer la vie sociale la vie
économique l'administration le champ
politique et je voulais lui montrer que
rien et à qui rien n'est définitif tout
peut être remis en cause
et c'est cette histoire-là du xxème
siècle où on voit qu'il ya bien
évidemment eu des avancées mais il ya eu
des stagnations il ya eu des reculs et
que si les femmes et les hommes
d'ailleurs ne sont pas vigilants et bien
nous pouvons retourner en arrière
on le voit bien aujourd'hui
en europe pas simplement franc je pense
à la pologne avec la difficulté qu'ont
les femmes à obtenir des avortements et
qu'elles se font souvent maintenant dans
la clandestinité
donc ça c'est ma la question s'est posée
à nouveau en espagne rési remarque te
ment vous avez raison et c'est pour ça
que ce livre il s'adresse aux jeunes il
s'adresse aux jeunes filles qui pensent
que tout est bien dans le meilleur des
mondes
les jeunes filles et les jeunes hommes
et les jeunes sont pas les oublier mais
c'est vrai mais en même temps je pense
qu'on peut attendre aussi beaucoup des
femmes parce que ce sont les premières
victimes de l'inégalité et des
difficultés ça c'est ma première
approche la deuxième est bien vous voyez
bien comme moi nous sommes dans un
contexte où finalement beaucoup de
thèses populistes avance et on a un peu
l'impression que la diversité à regarder
de façon un peu négative voire
stigmatisant et vous allez on a même
entendu le mot de retour du mot du mot
de français de souche et bien j'ai voulu
faire d'une pierre deux coups c'est à
dire que cette finalement ce cette cause
féminine ses droits des femmes je
voulais les faire incarné par des femmes
issues de la diversité et donc montré
que non seulement cette diversité n'a
pas été un fardeau n'est qu'elle a été
plutôt facteurs de réussite de
compétences alors quand on commence avec
marie curie prix nobel et qu'on termine
par adjani enfin quand je dis marie
curie s'est pas vraiment vrai puisque la
première femme issue de la diversité qui
a obtenu une place extrêmement
importante au niveau de la discipline
qu'elle incarne et c'est lille al haski
la première puisque à 11 ans elle était
l été a pris le premier prix du
conservatoire elle était harpiste et à
16 ans tenez vous bien
lily laskine la première à avoir intégré
le grand orchestre de paris et
savez-vous que lily laskine étaient
russes et donc j'en profite pour faire
un focus sur les flux d'immigration qui
permette qui permettent d'expliquer que
la france elle est faite et qu'elle
appartient à non seulement aux français
desouche néo-français de branchages et
donc j'ai construit ce livre autour de
décade avec ces pionnières et que je le
dis encore ça commence par lesdits les
skins et ça se termine par adjani avec
une immigration maghrébine et j'ai voulu
dire que ces pionnières sont très
importantes dans notre récit national et
c'est vrai que si je vous dis comment
dirais-je françoise giraud vous allez me
dire c'est une patronne de presse c'est
la première femme ministre ministre de
l'éducation et on oublie être de pardon
des droits des femmes même je n'oublie
mon latin mais savez vous qu'elle était
d'origine turque
donc c'est ça que je voulais montrer
c'est la banalisation de cette
immigration de toutes ces histoires
nationales et surtout dans un deuxième
temps j'ai voulu dire parce que je veux
pas que les choses soient figées
c'est pas simplement des pionnières il
ya aussi des héritières alors fadila
mehal j'aimerais qu'on revienne aussi à
la forme de ce livre c'est un livre
constitué de courts articles et de
photographies c'est très important
puisque vous avez écrit ce livre
finalement pour votre fille et puis pour
toutes les jeunes femmes d'aujourd'hui
j'insiste pour dire que c'est un livre
que les hommes doivent lire aussi car
l'histoire des femmes les concerne au
premier chef fadila mehal
c'est un livre que vous adressez je
dirais d'abord à la jeune génération
vous avez raison il s'adresse aussi aux
hommes parce que sans l'alliance fécond
de des hommes et des femmes
nous n'y arriverons pas alors pourquoi
ce livre est aussi gelé voulu danser je
suis président de la commission culture
vous l'avez rappelé entente que comme
donc conseillère de paris
je suis très attaché à la forme alors
évidemment la forme ne doit pas au je
dirais mettre en avant simplement la
forme et éviter de parler du contenu
mais je pense qu'il faut qu'il soit
rayons il faut qu'ils soient
pédagogiques
donc c'est pour ça que il ya à la fois
faux cul sur une femme emblématique de
france il ya le regard sur l'europe et
même au delà que ce qu'on fait beaucoup
référence aux anglo saxons et puis j'ai
voulu construire en bas du livre d
des dates spécifiques des dates
importantes pour la cause des femmes et
avoir peut-être autour de chaque de
chaque décade un titre symbolique qui
pourrait annoncer un peu la thématique
de l'année
je pense par exemple l'année 1900 avec
le temps des pionnières l'année 1950
avec le temps de l'engagement la
libération des corps bien évidemment
avec 1920 et puis le temps de la
reconnaissance à partir des années 90 et
des années 2000 et vous avez raison il
faut que ce livre il soit approprié j'ai
pas voulu faire un livre prêchi prêcha
avec énormément de données j'ai voulu
faire des textes très courts
c'est-à-dire notamment qu'on peut
recommander aux enseignants car ça peut
être aussi un livre à lire en classe
vous avez raison vous avez raison je
pense que c'est tout le travail que va
faire l'association les mariannes de la
diversité qui a peu le partenaire de
cette édition et je crois que c'est très
important en effet que les mois je pense
que les contenus il dort est accessible
c'est à dire parce que et puis après
peut-être retenir une idée importante
par chapitre et de façon à pouvoir
cheminer dans le siècle et et voir
finalement que moi c'est vous savez je
suis de ceux qui sont qui ont décidé
d'être positif donc bien évidemment home
avancera toutes les difficultés liées
aux migrations et on le voit bien avec
le dernier rapport de l'europe qui
explique comment les l'immigration je
dirais légal a complètement explosé mais
je veux dire que notre modèle
d'intégration est quand même une
référence et que de mon point de vue il
continuera à fonctionner pour peu que
les valeurs et surtout que la promesse
républicaine soit au rendez vous et donc
ce livre aussi parle d' inégalités et je
voulais dire aussi que pourquoi j'ai
gmail et finalement ces deux dimensions
féministe et
et diversité parce que je pense que ce
sont deux problématiques identiques la
façon dont on parle et je pense aux
années 1900 de la marche parce que les
femmes même si elle était presque
majoritaire puisqu'elles sont en tout
cas en parité
elle était considérée comme la marche
d'ailleurs des expressions ouvrage de
dames
voilà un montre bien finalement cette
distance par rapport à elles et les
immigrés c'est la même chose c'est la
marge est donc moi je pense aujourd'hui
que dans notre république c'est la
marche qui tient la feuille et je le dis
d'autant plus que c'est la façon dont on
traite cette marche qui informe du
niveau de civilisation d'une société et
donc c'est très important d'avoir
regardé de très près et c'est pour ça
que je pense que c'est ces deux
problématiques sont intimement liés et
qu'elles sont articulés alors votre
livre fadila mehal reprend aussi les
grandes dates correspondant à des
conquêtes pour les femmes en france et
dans le monde vous vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure il y à 70 ans en 1945 les
femmes obtenaient le droit de vote en
france on se dit que les femmes ont été
finalement les grandes oubliées la
révolution française même si elles ont
joué un rôle certain comme olympe de
gouges ou madame roland 70 ans seulement
devrait-on 10 avait raison 70 ans moi je
vous somme et puis je n'oublie pas que
dans partout dans le monde et à radio
orient vous en faites souvent le
témoignage des gens et des femmes et des
hommes meurent aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
veulent voter et qui veulent exprimer
leur point de vue le pluralisme et la
démocratie
donc c'est quand même un fait majeur
aujourd'hui de pouvoir voter
et rappelez vous c'est ce que vous
soulignez il ya simplement 70 ans que ce
droit a été acquis et je crois que c'est
olympe de gouges qui disait les femmes
peuvent aller aller à l'échafaud d'eau
qu'elles peuvent en effet allés à la
tribune alors aujourd'hui vous avez vu
le nombre incalculable fin calculable y
en a eu deux de loi pour la parité en
politique
et vous avez vu comme moi quand vous
regardez la télévision le mercredi après
midi et vous voyez en effet que c'est
des rangs l'assemblée nationale a
également le mercredi elle a dit vous
avez raison de le rappeler
elle va céder ses dires en monochrome et
souvent masculine alors vous parliez de
d'invisibilité je crois que c'est
vraiment le terme qui convient c'est
l'invisibilité
parce que en effet la considération de
leurs rapports n'étaient pas tout à fait
reconnu aujourd'hui malgré tous ces
efforts vous l'avez dit aussi à
l'assemblée nationale basse et 80 % qui
sont encore des hommes et des hommes
d'une cinquantaine d'années et qui sont
en effet très peu proche de la diversité
j'allais dire heureusement qu'il ya des
territoires d'outre-mer pour colorer un
peu ses rangs la alors la loi veil
permettant l'avortement c'est l'une des
grandes avancées pour les femmes
vous avez raison on a fêté c'est le 40e
anniversaire de la loi vous avez vu
comme moi les documents d'archivés qui
était pleine d'émotion de voir cette
femme à siéger
comment partout de boutoir parents
parfois des déclarations je dirais
intempestives et même un peu un peu une
élégante cette femme cette grande dame
avec bien sûr le soutien de son
président je veux quand même le signaler
qu' il ya des régions valéry giscard
d'estaing qui avait une vraie volonté
d'aller jusqu'au bout mais cela n'allait
pas de soi
et je peux vous assurer qu aujourd'hui
en europe je pense notamment la pologne
où le poids du religieux est très fort
il ya des femmes qui ne peuvent pas
accéder à l'intégrité de leur corps est
le choix qui est fait pour une maternité
voulu simone veil a cessé toute vie
publique en raison de la maladie
c'est une personnalité pour laquelle
vous avez beaucoup d'admiration belle
ville un modèle pour elle bien
évidemment évidemment je pense que c'est
une femme qui conjugue à la fois
l'intégrité politique elle était
centriste comme et donc elle était
capable de transcender les co la preuve
on l'a vu sur beaucoup de sujets et
c'est aussi une femme qui a donné de sa
vie qui a connu l'enfer de la
déportation et donc qui je pense devant
l'un des cibles a été capable de
construire et de donner aux autres et je
pense que ça c'est un engagement qu'on
ne peut que saluer alors on remonte le
temps j'ai parlé du droit de vote des
femmes en 1945 la loi devait y en 1974
plus récemment l'année 1992 sous
françois mitterrand a permis deux
avancées la loi sanctionnant le
harcèlement sexuel sur le lieu de
travail et la loi sanctionnant les
violences conjugales
aujourd'hui plus personne ne remet en
question ses lois est-ce qu'à l'époque
ces textes allait de soi alors je
voulais quand même avant parce que je
lui ai pas dit et c'est regrettable
c'est que la première partie a été conçu
avec tous les historiens de la shac les
bâtisseurs de mémoire et notamment avec
eux pascal blanchard et donc c'est un
travail vraiment d'historiens c'est pas
j'ai dirigé ce se livre donc je me suis
appuyé sur beaucoup d' expertise et on a
repris ensemble avec le choix des
historiens mais aussi ma validation les
grands moments vous avez raison de
souligner que la loi sur le harcèlement
a été un cas puisque ce qui était
considéré finalement comme j'allais dire
des comportements de séduction est
devenu maintenant un délit et c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'on voit que quand
on est dans une relation de
subordination avec une autorité ou avec
un employeur c'est difficile parfois de
de se défendre la loi sur sur la
violence faite aux femmes
c'est une loi très importante parce que
quand on a fait les diagnostics on s'est
rendu compte quand même une femme tous
les trois jours meurent en france sous
les coups de son conjoint et donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
pouvait pas laisser faire et continuer
il ya eu cette grande cause nationale à
laquelle moi j'ai participé en tant que
présidente d'une association
on était 22 associations pour porter
finalement cette cette volonté que
soient identifiés la con c'était pas
facile puisque vous savez beaucoup
considéré à l'époque que les violences
familiales
c'est de l'ordre du privé donc vous me
répondez que ces textes n'allait pas de
soi c'est véritablement soit large et
aucun détour loïc céderait pour aller
assez vous faites bien rire mais je
crois que vous avez compris que oui
c'est une évidence que ça n'allait pas
de soi
on frappe sa femme c'est du domaine du
privé voilà les harcèlements dans
l'entreprise c'est du domaine du privé
aujourd'hui on essaye d'avoir un espace
public qu'ils soient alors encadrés et
surtout qui puisse permettre la dignité
des femmes l'invité de plurielles et
fadila mehal fondatrice des mariannes de
la diversité présidente de la commission
culture au conseil de paris élue du
xviiie arrondissement et conseillère de
paris
fadela al je rappelle que vous publiez
marianne les femmes et la diversité dans
la république aux éditions de l'atelier
alors je remonte encore le temps n'a
parlé de la loi de 1992 sanctionnant les
violences conjugales en 2002 donc plus
récemment ségolène royal a créé le congé
de paternité qui permet au père de
prendre un temps de repos pour s'occuper
de leurs nouveau nés comme les femmes
finalement une mesure qu'eric zemmour a
dénoncé en accusant les socialistes de
vouloir transformer les pères en mer
c'est finalement un des exemples que
vous
cité dans depuis le début de cette
émission de mesures qui peuvent être
remises en cause aujourd'hui vous avez
raison de la vente je vais juste
reprendre quand vous dites de permettre
par le congé parental une année où enfin
selon les la réglementation de repos non
ce n'est pas du repos
c'est vraiment un investissement de la
partie science que quand on femme de
revault de repos par rapport au travail
va effectivement quand la jeune izia pas
de l'eau pour cette saison de me
reprendre
vous avez désormais elle dit aussi des
choses alors vous avez raison en effet
tout peut être remis en question la
preuve le livre de derrick de moudon je
vous ferai pas la publicité mais lui il
a un vrai une vraie dimension presque
psychanalytique et vis-à-vis des femmes
notre vis-à-vis des immigrés
l'impression que les que les hommes ont
perdu leur virilité au profit des femmes
et que rétablir l'égalité c'est pas
c'est rétablir l'égalité pour lui une
forme de violence par rapport au statut
hérité des traditions de deux sans doute
et que ça c'est quand même je pense que
même heureusement j'allais dire beaucoup
de jeunes et beaucoup de personnes et
beaucoup d'hommes ne sont pas dans cette
danse est dans cette démarche enfin ils
sont pas dans cette dérive
en effet au considéré que le fait de
reprendre l'égalité pour les femmes est
une source de de privation de droits des
hommes roux de leur atteinte à leur
intégrité c'est quelque chose de fou
c'est quelque chose vraiment qui relève
de l'appel de la psychanalyste zemmour
on va pas faire la publicité pour ces
mots mais c'est vrai qu'il a peur des
femmes et la peur des immigrés et c'est
en ça que je te dis les choses sont lus
et délais les choses sont complètement
lié et je pense que ségolène royal a
raison d'insister sur ce fait là est de
tenir en tout cas on sera à ses côtés
pour en effet faire en sorte que ce
droit
en effet pour d'éducation soient
partagés par les hommes et les femmes
quand ils le veulent
un fadila mehal comment vous avez vécu
ce moment qu'on a appelé la polémique
sur la théorie des genres quand najat
vallaud belkacem à vous
lui que dans l'école on insiste un petit
peu plus pour permettre aux petites
filles de s'orienter vers des métiers
qui ne soit pas forcément féminin mais
ça pouvait être aussi des métiers
masculins
ça a été récupéré cette volonté oui on a
parlé de la polémique sur la théorie des
genres comme on avait vécu cette période
oui vous avez raison c'est un moment un
peu difficile parce que je l' ai vécu
parfois comme une agression comme
toujours quand les choses sont
caricaturés et qu' il ya l'injonction au
genre et c'est vrai que c'est une
question de bon sens aujourd'hui
il faut rétablir l'égalité faut
déconstruire les préjugés
il faut absolument en effet que les
petites jeunes filles et les filles même
en maternelle puisse comprendre que l on
des itinéraires différents du fait de
leur sexe et qu'elles boivent à voix je
dirais un avenir plus ouverts si elle le
souhaite mais ça n'a pas été compris
comme ça paye notamment dans les cafés
populaires y mais il ya eu quand même
des injonctions à c'est assez je le
dirai de façon très subtile mais assez
assez verticale dans un sens où tous
passés par le genre et moi je réfute
complètement cette idéologie
parce que je considère que dans une
identité personnelle
nous sommes au delà de tout ce qu'on
peut dire on ne sent pas que des femmes
nous avons d'autres identités le fait
d'être enseignant le fait d'être
d'origine étrangère le fait d'être dans
une zone urbaine ou rurale
le fait d'être est donc trop focalisé
que ça devenait presque une obsession et
je crois que c'est ça qui à un moment
fragilisée cette conception parce que du
coup tout était regardé à travers ce
prisme et donc avec parfois comme
d'ailleurs tous les les convertis qui
ont envie absolument que cette thèse et
je pense que ça a choqué parce qu'il y
avait des choses qui ne méritait pas en
effet d'être dénoncés ou d'être trop mis
en avant
et donc c'est ça dans les quartiers
populaires c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une
prise en compte et même caricature de ça
moi j'ai vu circuler quand je faisais ma
campagne des délits
on disait mustapha va devenir une femme
et on décrivait comment les hommes
allaient se transformer en femme et non
alors que dans la réalité ce n'était pas
ce qui est dit et été dit ce qui était
dit c'est que les femmes doivent pouvoir
accès c'est accéder et doivent dépasser
les stéréotypes qui leur sont attachés
je veux dire par exemple on a tendance à
dire que les hommes et bien ils sont
plus directs qui sont forts ils sont
plus comment dirais-je tourné vers
l'extérieur que les femmes c'est plutôt
des aptitudes comme dont on dit qu'elles
sont féminines c'est à dire plus
intériorisée plus dans les coupes ben
moi je je je défends qu'une femme peut
être forte tourné vers l'extérieur et
qu'elle nomme peut être tout à fait
sensible et avoir des capacités des
coudes donc c'est là dessus je pense
qu'on peut tous être d'accord alors
après dire que je ne peux te voir qu'à
travers cette finalement ce filtre du
genre moi je suis opposé parce que je
suis de ceux qui militent pour que des
identités plurielles puisse permettre à
chaque individu de ces de s'épanouir
fadila mehal il n'y a que deux femmes au
panthéon
germaine tillon et geneviève anthonioz
de gaulle feront bientôt leur entrée au
panthéon comme vous dites deux femmes
honorées par l'arrêt 2015 donc il
s'agira des troisième et quatrième femme
à recevoir cet honneur
ce sera un moment fort de l'année 2015
ça sera un moment très fort notamment
pour line madame anthonioz que sur son
travail qu'elle a menée avec l'atelier
atd quart monde et donc sur la question
de l'exclusion moi je crois que c'est
très important
alors on me dira évidemment c'est une
femme qui se préoccupe des questions
sociales mais je crois que c'est très
important
puis-je amène tillon qui germait liant
l'algérie très très fort avec l'algérie
qui résistent en résistance et qui a été
de ceux qui ont mis à mal la torture en
algérie et qu'ils ont fait alors c'est
vrai que les gi la guillotine n'ont pas
disparu mais je pense qu'elle a été un
élément très fort et très structurant
pour la une remise en cause et pour ont
finalement une interpellation à l'époque
des intellectuels qui ont parti
ici p d'une certaine façon très active à
la libération de l'algérie
donc ce sont des moments en effet
symbolique très très fort auquel je
participerai en tout cas j'attacherai
une très grande importance ce fadila
mehal vous avez choisie pour la
couverture de votre livre une marianne
noir joséphine baker est ce qu'elles
auraient mérité d'entrer au panthéon
écouter alors là c'est à apprécier si
vous voulez moi je pense que joséphine
baker a fait des choses formidables sur
la libération des corps et ça c'est
important à une époque c'était 1920 ou
en effet le corps pour se tait et on
sortait finalement d'une période un peu
douloureuse après la guerre donc elle a
fait beaucoup c'est une grande
résistante personne ne le sait mais je
pense qu'il a fallu faire des choix et
donc le panthéon c'est quand même
quelque chose qui tend vers l'universel
je crois que en tout cas la lutte contre
l'exclusion c'est quelque chose qui
parle à tout le monde et puis les
militants de l'anticolonialisme aussi
c'est quelque chose qui transcende donc
voilà je ferai pas de comparaisons mais
joséphine baker tient une place très
importante
allez vous en parler bien sûr dans le
large en parle parce qu'on ne connaît
que ce côté ludique et musicale mais je
pense que nous nous avons essayé de
prendre la femme vraiment dans sa
globalité dans ce qu'elle a pu apporter
à la société alors vous faites référence
à la photo magnifique dalle lte qui paie
skil qui est paru en 2003 de cette
marianne noir avec le bonnet phrygien
qui est en couleurs bleu blanc rouge
et c'est très important d'abord parce
qu'elle s'appelle marianne et que
marianne ça fait référence à meriem ça
fait référence à marie et donc sa part
le modèle le modèle mariam mariam sais
et je pense que c'est important
alors c'est vrai qu'on aurait voulu que
cette marianne soit déclinée en allant
du blanc jusque là la couleur noire mais
elle est tellement belle
elle est tellement et vous avez vu
qu'elle regarde vers l'avenir cette
marianne c'est important pour nous parce
que je pense que l'avenir de la france
c'est cette france métissée
c'est cette france que nous aimons quand
elle est ouverte quand elle est
généreuse s quand elle croise ses
valeurs fadila mehal votre livre est un
livre je dirais aussi pédagogique est ce
que vous pouvez d'abord nous expliquer
ce que représente marianne pour vous
puisque vous avez fondé cette
association les mariannes de la
diversité c est véritablement un lien
avec la révolution française avec la
liberté l'égalité vous avez raison c'est
la personnification c'est l'emblème
c'est marianne voilà en train de
défendre l'unité de la république moi je
pense que des choses communes il ya il
ya d'une comment dirais-je un fonds qui
aujourd'hui fait que nous regardons dans
la même direction
je crois que c'est renault qui disait la
république c'est un plébiscite
permanents et donc ses valeurs d'unité
de cohérence de concorde aussi parce que
marianne ce n'est pas la division et moi
je fais un clin d'oeil à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui font la hiérarchie des
civilisations et la lutte des
civilisations ça c'est la première chose
c'est marianne mêlée en couleur elle est
en couleur comme nos rues comme j'allais
dire à nos prisons bien sûr mais aussi
nos écoles nos universités et donc elle
est plurielle elle est métissée elle et
c'est marianne la république et c'est la
diversité les républicains et je pense
que les républicains ne peuvent que
soutenir cette république cette promesse
républicaine pour peu et là je suis
assez solennel qu'elle applique ses
valeurs qu'elle applique ses valeurs
notamment la valeur d'égalité de
fraternité alors j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur ce moment très fort qui a
été le 11 janvier vous avez manifesté
comme tout le monde je suis charles
place de la république
après les attentats du 7 8 et 9 janvier
la république finalement pour vous
qu'est ce que c'est vous dites qu'elle
doit promettre l'égalité vous avez le
sentiment que les jeunes qui ne sont pas
allés manifester
c'était une façon pour eux deux
d'appeler à l'aide la république ceux
qui sont pas allés manifester
je pense qu'il ya quand même une vraie
interrogation aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
vu pas mal de d'événements autour des
moments de silence de recueillement ou
une remise en cause
moi je crois que en effet pour certains
jeunes aujourd'hui très fragilisée par
la question sociale vous savez que dans
nos quartiers populaires il ya parfois
40 % de taux de chômage et un tour de
réussite scolaire qui est extrêmement
bas donc je paris grainé toutes les
statistiques et qui peuvent aujourd'hui
ce refus réfugiés vers des identités des
identités parfois mythifié et est ce que
je même en opposition c'est des
identités meurtrières qui vaut jusqu'au
bout de cette nuit wismes d'une certaine
façon jusqu'à tuer jusqu'à prôner la
haine et donc qu'ils peuvent être
enfermé parce qu'il ya aussi des
prédicateurs il ya aussi l'influencé des
réseaux sociaux et des sites que vous
connaissez comme moi et donc ils peuvent
basculer le passage à l'acte il peut
basculer en disant je ne suis pas
charlie pour autant je crois qu'il y a
moyen aujourd'hui de travailler sur ce
les causes finalement 17 il ya aussi
tous ceux qui n'ont pas manifesté qui
n'ont pas voulu dire je ne suis pas
charlie et qui ne sont pas des tueurs
potentiels qui sont avérés les gens qui
s'interrogent sur les caricatures sur la
liberté de la presse et des raisons ça
c'est autre chose moi je vous parle de
ce qui visiblement avaient manifesté de
façon assez forte
leur opposition à charlie et était
plutôt pour je dirais une relation quand
même relativement compatissante
vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont mené les
attaques
alors après il ya toutes ces parties de
la population nombreuse qui a considéré
que le blasphème
en tout cas religieux dans une religion
pour une religion qui est aussi
relativement stigmatiser vous bien
parler des actes anti musulmans
et bien ce n'était pas le moment et ce
n'était pas le ton alors moi je défends
la liberté d'expression et comme je le
dis souvent la liberté d'expression elle
accompagne avec un devoir de
responsabilité et donc c'est quelque
chose que j'adresse à tous les
journalistes qui à un moment donné ont
le devoir d'informer mais en même temps
de faire en sorte que l'impact de leurs
informations elle passe bien quand je
dis bien c'est qu'elle soit bien
approprié pour qu'on puisse en effet
chacun avancer et c'est vrai que
certains ont considéré que le fait dans
cette nébuleuse finalement difficile à
appréhender des anti musulman ça a
apporté encore une touche supplémentaire
dans la stigmatisation et que le
blasphème de ce point de vue pouvait
être un facteur de déstabilisation
moi j'ai toujours soutenu que tous les
journalistes pouvaient et même
d'ailleurs c'est essentiel pour notre
démocratie pouvoir exprimer leur humour
leur dérision parfois même leur violence
aussi pour certains par rapport à
certains à certains faits sociétaux donc
moi ça ne me gêne pas ça ne me choque
pas mais c'est vrai que des personnes
qui sont focalisés peut-être trop
investi sur la question religieuse au
sens parfois même politique
bon ça a pu générer en effet des
difficultés particulières
alors on est à deux semaines des
élections départementales vous n'êtes
pas candidate fadila mehal vous êtes
conseillère de paris élue du 18e s'est
déjà laissé déjà un conseil un conseil
général paris donc je suis déjà élu je
suis déjà conseillé alors c'est une
élection la parité est obligatoire les
départementales les 22 et 29 mars on
votera obligatoirement pour un homme et
pour une femme
en même temps c'est un progrès cadre
étendre à d'autres élections
c'est un très très grand progrès parce
que malheureusement aujourd'hui pour
entrer à l'assemblée nationale beaucoup
nous disent pour les femmes c'est d'être
suppléante quelqu'un qui veut risque
d'être ministre et donc comme ça il
libérera la place et ça vous permettra
de rentrer et sur ce sujet je voudrais
quand même apporté une petite nuance
vous savez moi j'ai fait mener des
études peu empirique sur le tas
concernant la parité chez les
parlementaires
et puis je me suis rendu compte que les
filles avaient plus de chance ici
l'immigration d'accéder que les hommes
et bien tout simplement ce que j'ai
interrogé un peu nos amis députés et les
partis aussi les grandes parties la
façon dont il fonctionne et me disent on
va pas se faire hara-kiri deux fois
d'autocad laisser nos places laissons
les à des femmes en plus issus de la
diversité parce que du coup ça pourra
faire d'une pierre deux coups donc vous
voyez comme quoi de ces comme en
mathématiques deux mois ça peut devenir
un puce donc c'est finalement plus
difficile de réussir en politique quand
on est un homme issu de la diversité
plus de la femme
ah ça c'est une évidence ailleurs on le
voit dans les gouvernements mais c'est
une évidence et d'ailleurs c'est un
point qu'il faudra alors équilibrée pour
ne pas attiser la colère des jeunes gens
qui je le dis comme les femmes souffrent
énormément dans leur insertion
professionnelle et sociale
alors depuis l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy qui avait nommé des femmes
emblématiques comme rama yade et rachida
dati jusqu'à françois hollande qui a
nommé najat vallaud belkacem au
ministère de l'éducation nationale on
imagine plus un gouvernement sans
ministres issus de la diversité
représentant la diversité est ce que
vous pensez que ces nominations dans les
gouvernements peuvent être remises en
question puisque vous dites que rien
n'est acquis bien c'est une tradition à
laquelle on ne touchera plus aujourd'hui
ce que c'était une révolution
copernicienne
on peut dire ce qu'on veut de sarkozy je
l' ai combattu en son temps mais ils
avaient vraiment réussi je dirais cette
révolution culturelle c'est à dire
d'admettre de faire admettre que dans
des postes régaliens des personnes
issues de l'immigration pouvait
y avoir droit alors c'est vrai qu'après
il a un peut dénaturer les propos quand
il a dit rachida dati au ministère de la
justice compte tenu de son origine
bon là ça a mis un énorme froid mais en
même temps je pense qu'ils peuvent plus
revenir en arrière parce que du coup si
vous voulez un gouvernement l'image de
la photo de famille c'est un peu délicat
alors moi je pense que là dessus c'est
comme un acquis que ce sera quand même
difficile pour un parti par contre je
pense qu'il ya encore des bastilles avec
elle va dans la haute administration
vous savez qu'on va nommer le prochain
phanom est désigné par le csa le
prochain président de france télévisions
jean sur les médias c'est immense il ya
un vrai travail aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup on a quand même des conseillers
ace diversité mais ce qu'on souhaiterait
vraiment c'est qu un président ou une
présidente sein de l'émigration pense
que ça serait même très utile ou même de
l'outre-mer parce qu'il ya des vraies
compétences aujourd'hui qui existent et
qui ne demande qu'à prendre des
responsabilités
c'est valable je pense qu'il ya des
renouvellements là qui vont se faire
dans d'autres médias mais voilà c'est
des choses qui sont difficiles à
cueillir pourquoi et je reprend la
formule hier dans une autre radio de
françois bayroux que j'ai accompagné et
qui disait finalement la gouvernance en
france quand même la gouvernance entre
soi à la française c'est à dire il est
de bon ton d'être sorti de l'ena d'avoir
fait sciences po si c'est possible des
cabinets et que ce sont les nouveaux
gestionnaires alors si vous faites hcc
encore mieux et c'est les nouveaux
gestionnaires de tous les établissements
publics et privés vous l'avez vu
d'ailleurs avec beaubourg qui vient
d'être qui vient d'être vous le nouveau
président vient d'être désigné on a vu
aussi la jeune garde qui accompagne le
président hollande à l'elysée
une seule femme et puis personnes issues
de l'immigration voilà donc entre soi et
vous verrez leur pedigree sont tous
sortis des grandes écoles
donc tout ça
m'attriste un peu parce que il me semble
que la compétence mais je la remets pas
en cause académique là mais les gens de
terrain les gens qui ont vraiment
regarder de près les choses qui ont
acquis un bagage qui ont même parfois un
certain âge il on a besoin de ça et
aujourd'hui ne pas être parrainé par les
uns ou par les autres ne pas avoir le
réseau suffisant ne pas avoir les
diplômes qu'il faut qui vous ouvrent des
sésames
et bien c'est une vraie difficulté c'est
pour ça que les élites aujourd'hui sont
en train ou du moins les citoyens sont
en train de se désaffilier par rapport à
nous dirigeants une partie de la droite
réclame l'interdiction du voile à
l'université
votre ami socialiste pascale boitard
secrétaire d'état aux droits des femmes
ne réclame pas une loi d'interdiction
mais elle a déclaré que le voile n'avait
pas sa place à l'université
est ce que ce débat doit avoir lieu ou
bien vous pensez que c'est un débat
malsain
alors pascal que j'aime beaucoup
franchement là elle aurait dû être un
peu plus prudent dans son affirmation
pourquoi d'abord on est en période
électorale
moi j'ai toujours vu après vingt ans de
deux mondes politique c'est toujours
dans ces périodes là qu'on agite le
chiffon rouge et le chiffon rouge c'est
pas compliqué c'est toujours
l'admiration de maintenance et l'islam
donc sur le calendrier je me pose des
questions ce qu'on veut vraiment apaiser
les choses
je crois qu'il faut sortir de ces
périodes là parce que d'abord c'est
instrumentalise et puis on n'est pas sûr
de dire vraiment ce qu'on pense
on le dit pour pouvoir faire monter ou
les uns ou les autres donc ça c'est très
regrettable
après sur le débat sur le voile mois
chacun connaît mes convictions j'ai voté
fin j'ai goûté j'étais pas marne
heureusement pas encore parlementaire si
on la voit là sur la burqa est sur la
voie le voile dans les écoles
donc on me connaît on sait que je suis
par nature opposé pourquoi par nature et
je dirais même un peu par expérience
puisque je suis natif d'algérie j'ai
connu la décennie noire dans ces
périodes là et j'ai su très vite que le
foulard était finalement le cheval de
troie pour avancer davantage parce que
c'est toujours un marqueur de l'emprise
des femmes dans l'espace public donc là
dessus je n'ai pas
tadam mais par contre sur l'université
pour d'abord entendre ce que disent les
représentants des enseignants des
directeurs
est ce qu'il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui qui fait que les choses se
gère très mal dans l'université ça
mériterait une vraie réflexion une vraie
question
avant d'avancer de jeter en pâture ce
débat et puis moi je voudrais dire aussi
aux musulmans parce qu'ils sont nombreux
ici qui écoute votre émission
il me semble que le prophète avait dit
que le voile était là pour protéger les
femmes est protégé à une époque où en
effet on pouvait les confondre avec ou
avec les esclaves ou susciter la
concupiscence des hommes
et aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire c'est
le vrai voile qui protège les femmes
c'est l'éducation
c'est l'éducation c'est la formation
c'est ça qui leur permettra d'aller
alors si elles doivent choisir entre le
voile est de rester à la maison et
d'être exclu de cette formidable
opportunité qu'est l'école
moi je leur demande vraiment de
réfléchir à cette question et la
question en tout cas ne se pose pas pour
l'instant donné des ailes et elle est
d'une certaine façon elle n'est pas
d'actualité elle est décalée par rapport
à la réalité
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important quand on fait des élections
départementales c'est de parler du
chômage
je voulais 10 40 % dans certains
quartiers c'est de parler de l'éducation
300000 personnes enfants ou jeunes
sortent de l'appareil scolaire sans
formation
voilà des questions essentielles le
gouvernement a décidé de lancer un
dialogue avec des nouveaux visages de
l'islam de france avec une structure qui
complèterait le cfcm
comment vous regardez cette réforme en
cours dans l'organisation de l'ue culte
musulman en france vais écouter
j'applaudis des deux mains moi j'étais
de ceux qui ont toujours appelé militer
pour y ait un islam de france laïque
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un pan entier
de la population qui avait les musulmans
je le rappelle ont des pratiques très
différentes
l'anah qui font cinq fois par jour leur
prière d'autres qui le sont moins mais
ils sont croyants ils sont croyants mais
ils ont un rapport à la religion qui est
différent on peut même être dos de jeu
et de deux tracks tueur mature
arabo-islamique sans être pour autant
exclus de la communauté en tant que tel
donc honnêtement je pense que c'est une
très très bonne chose que cette majorité
silencieuse cette majorité il faut le
dire elles puissent aussi être
représentés pas simplement sur les
questions de théologie mais sur les
effets d'impact sur les aspects
culturels
moi je j'ai vu que sur le csl c'est une
avancée je veux pas non plus ils ont
leur rôle et il faut qu'il travaille
davantage n'y a pas de femmes et si on
représente les musulmans à travers le
met des mètres carrés de surface des
lieux de culte il est évident que la
majorité sont des hommes
vous pourriez participer à ce dialogue
fadila mehal va écouter pour le moment
on m'a pas sollicité mais voilà moi de
toute façon je suis une femme de bonne
volonté
et s'il faut que j'apporte ma pierre à
l'édifice je le ferai mais pour le
moment je pense que cette initiative et
et vertueuse
elle est louable et honnêtement je là je
la soutiens complètement même si elle
n'est même pas deux j'allais dire de mon
parti politique
dernière question les propos de manuel
valls hier sur europe 1 ont fait couler
beaucoup d'encre il a exprimé sa crainte
de voir le fn remporté les
départementales voire l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 est ce que c'est
une crainte que vous partagez pas une
ville a raison de dire qu'il ya eu des
opportunités aux armes et en même temps
on va pas continuer à stigmatiser le
front national de parler du front
national matin midi et soir de le mettre
au centre des débats
et puis après d'être étonné qu'ils
soient aujourd'hui au score où il est et
que même parfois certains partis racole
j'allais dire donc autour de ses terres
moi moi je vraiment au rouge et une
attitude est extrêmement sereine et il
faut parler aux électeurs du front
national tous les électeurs du front
national ne sont pas pour la lutte des
civilisations faut être honnête
moi j'étais dans le xviiie j'ai fait
campagne au mois d'avril au mois de mars
dernier je suis allé aux portes du
xviiie et vous savez que population
extrêmement fragile
extrêmement parfois même certains
désocialisés et la crainte est énorme de
les voir basculer vers le front national
eh bien non quand vous leur tenait des
propos de fermeté et mais républicains
et que vous leur expliquer qu'on doit
marcher des deux pieds à la fois avec un
accueil
je dirais positif et bienveillant à
l'altérité
mais en même temps que celle ci doit
respecter nos valeurs et doivent faire
montre aussi je dirais d'une volonté
individuelle de participer à notre pacte
républicain
le front national était à 8% donc les
républicains sont là et je pense qu'il
faut absolument bien évidemment tenir
compte des rôles que jouent aujourd'hui
le front national mais en même temps ne
faut pas être dans l'obsession comme le
fait aujourd'hui le gouvernement
ça ne fait et ce sont des agents presque
recruteur pour le front national donc
soyons sera faisons ce que nous avons à
faire parlons de ce qui préoccupe c'est
français et vous verrez la confiance
renaîtra merci fadila mehal je rappelle
que vous êtes fondatrice des mariannes
de la diversité présidente de la
commission culture au conseil de paris
élue du xviiie conseillère de paris
et surtout je renvoie nos auditeurs à ce
livre que je recommande à tout le monde
marianne les femmes et la diversité dans
la république un livre que vous allez
diriger aux éditions de l'atelier
mariane juste loïc marianne avec un
grand s au pluriel